impact investment is one of the fastest
growing sectors in the world at the
moment and i think that it's kind of in
the same place as what corporate social
responsibility was about 25 years ago
and it's going to get to a place where
it's suddenly a lot more the language
has to change the market signals have to
change your narrative around being able
to understand that everything is
interconnected and that you that what
you do matters is going to change i'm
i'm an optimist from that perspective
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lomitek and
sponsored by homework ventures hippo
insurance opposed hillary stanford leap
and birthright excel
welcome to another episode of 20 minute
leaders today i'm joined by tia
goldstein tia believes that business has
the power to make the world a better
place and that understanding and
operating with congruence kindness and
curiosity makes for a more interesting
and worthwhile life journey for the past
25 years she has been skipping across
the globe exploring and developing
practical frameworks strategies tools
and programs around sustainability
impact tech scaling social impact esg
sdg and any other random combination of
the alphabet that means doing good
tia goldstein welcome to 20 minute
leaders how are you
i am fantastic thank you how are you
good thank you very very much for taking
the time to be on this show and i i love
talking about sustainability and impact
people's journey into this field how
your work how you have been working with
the startup ecosystem to bridge the gap
between what the world needs and what is
actually happening but also now as
you're pursuing your your phd in the
subject looking more also from the
investing perspective and how the
investing world has actually quite a big
impact and responsibility when it comes
to
to to impact and sustainability and so
so tia take me back a little bit and
share with me
what what is impacting sustainability
what what does it mean that what were
you even talking about and then i'd love
to hear how you found yourself
making this a big part of your own
journey
okay um i think that first of all thank
you for having me i'm really excited
it's nice to be able to always nice to
be able to share any kind of uh any kind
of menu any any kind of venue to be able
to share the my passion around
sustainability and using business to be
able to make the world a better place is
always good
um
so i think i often get the question of
what is sustainability and what is
impact and i think that that's kind of
like saying how long is a piece of
string right
so
there are a lot of different ways to be
able to explain it i think that the
easiest one that i found is imagine a
world where the events that are
happening right now such as climate
change such as war such as gender
inequality
don't happen and that we live in harmony
in an environment where everything is
completely balanced uh sustainability
when you think about sustainability one
of the things to think about
is how can we create a future where the
resources
and everything else that we need is
basically we it's a self-sustaining
does that make sense
i think i think that makes a lot of
sense and so why
how how does this then relate to the
tech ecosystem and startups
okay so that's that's a much easier
question to answer rather than what is
the definition of sustainability because
i can go back to the brentwood report
and read you the exact definition but i
think that we live in a world where we
are relying more and more on innovation
and on technology in order to be able to
create a future for everyone and being
able to understand
what uh what impact that is going to
have and to be able to envision what
future we want to be able to create it's
important to kind of stop for a second
and understand that business has the
potential to make a difference we all
have the potential to make a difference
and how do we align what our values are
and what we decide to bring into the
world through technology to be able to
create a better world so impact tech is
something that i'm quite passionate
about
and impact tech is when we are using
technology to be able to solve uh
problems that are related to sustainable
development goals or related to wicked
problems or really very big and
complicated problems such as the ones
that we are looking at today such as
climate change
i don't know if you've seen some of the
things that are like for example the uh
the situation in afghanistan that's a
perfect example of wicked problems and
using technology for for the purpose of
good rather than for the purpose of um
something that is not really useful
within the world does that i hope that
that's a
better explanation tell me a little bit
about
your
your specific experiences with some
startups so give give me some concrete
ideas of of how you've been observing
companies leveraging technologies to
either solve some of those wicked
problems or or more in general talk
about you know sustainability and impact
for society
okay so i think that i i operate from
the i've operated from the belief that
business can change the world for a very
very long time and for the past 25 years
i've been kind of exploring a whole
bunch of different frameworks and tools
to be able to see how that can happen
and how do you create an ecosystem that
is going to create a positive
environment for entrepreneurs to be able
to make that choice of doing good rather
than creating something that is just
specifically for profit and it's been
really interesting to be able to see how
the shift of where social
entrepreneurship or corporate social
responsibility has gone and what the
journey we've been on with that and
right now i think that we're at a really
interesting place where the the idea of
being a social entrepreneur does no
longer is no longer as important and
people are much more there's a whole
brand of entrepreneurs that are waking
up and they're like well i actually want
to do something that is positive within
the world i want to be able to use
technology to be able to do that how do
i interweave purpose and profit in order
for that to be able to happen so
in terms of the specific ideas around
impact tech i mean there's multiple
different different examples of impact
tech
one example is for example using
blockchain blockchain is a technology
that a lot of us are not 100 sure what
exactly it means and usually when you
say blockchain it also means
cryptocurrency um which has an
association with bitcoin that for some
people can have a positive or a negative
connotation but blockchain itself
has the ability to actually have like a
permanent record so if you think about
all the different applications that you
can use that for for example in some
developing nations they use blockchain
technology in order to be able to
register who the land belongs to and
what the ownership of that land is so
when governments change then what
happens is that you go back to the
blockchain register and you're like well
hold on that was actually this farmer's
per this farmer's land you can't
appropriate it because it there's a
specific record around what it is
another fantastic company that is doing
amazing things around blockchain is the
um is leanne evans uh company um
i hope it's leonard
i know so many land um she used to be
the chief entrepreneur in queensland and
she has a company called everledger and
they specifically work on blockchain for
precious gems so if you think about
diamonds a lot of times the association
with diamonds is blood diamonds so being
able to understand how you can use
technology to ensure that the purpose
the purchase that you're doing is one
that is ethical that there is a
congruency throughout the whole supply
chain is something that is really
fantastic and then you can look at other
other ways to be able to look at tech
like for example bees
these are one of the foundations for our
food system
but there are massive issues with bees
so they're amazing companies that are
using machine learning to be able to uh
to take a look at what the health of the
bees is when they enter into the uh into
the hive and therefore be able to
identify some of the issues that the
hive have ahead of time i mean there's
there's a plethora of different examples
of of of impact tech and it's it's the
the imagine like there's no limit to the
imagination of what you can do with tech
and how you can focus it specifically on
something that is a positive cause
i i love it and i actually am i'm an
investor and a b hero which is doing
something that is of what you've just
described and i remember going into and
see the behaviors for the first time and
understanding how how these sensors are
actually you know
changing the way that farmers are
interacting with the far with with the
beehives and and our enablers of a new
consumer behavior which is just
phenomenal and i think that that's just
a a an amazing example of how technology
can can make a positive impact
in ways that we that we don't really
know into a time to anticipate now why
isn't this more common so as you've been
you know bridging the gap what are some
of the bigger challenges that you're
observing
well i think that one of the main
challenges which is why i'm why i'm
embarking on a phd is uh is basically
the the market signal around uh how if i
have if i am a tech and investor if i
have an idea and i'm looking for some
kind of way to be able to grow my
company really i only have three
different options in terms of being able
to fund my growth or to be able to
figure out a way to be able to do that
and generally speaking the the the match
between what i feel as a founder and i
have a passion for something that is
extremely important to me versus what
the investors expectations are are two
very different things and it doesn't
actually work with the concept of
sustainability so when you have and i if
a lot i know quite a few people that
have that i would consider to be impact
tech invest impact tech entrepreneurs
and they tried to seek funding and a lot
of the investors were like well no we're
actually not interested in what you're
doing because we don't see a scalable
growth or we don't see your ability to
be able to exit so you know investors
have vcs have a very very specific
outcome that they're looking for which
is a high return on investment and an
ipo within a certain amount of time and
when you look at different ecosystems
the way that that is measured in the way
that that what that focus is on is hyper
growth it focuses a lot of times on not
necessarily accomplishing the impact
that is that the count that the founder
is interested in accomplishing because
it might not necessarily be profitable
and we go back to this idea that
everything is disconnected rather than
everything is connected so first i had
you know the old notion of corporate
social responsibility was i have to make
money and then i'm going to be able to
do something good i'm going to i'm going
to dig a hole and then i'm going to
cover the whole say i'm sorry after i've
made my money versus this new fourth
wave of entrepreneurship which is you
can actually blend impact and and
finance and and uh success you just have
to know how to do it and you have to
know it's a different mindset around
what does what constitutes capital
because there are six different types of
capital and right now a lot of the focus
is only on financial capital rather than
being able to understand that you need a
whole bunch of different capital in
order to be able to grow a community and
to get a return on your investment and
expanding the notion around what that is
as you can see i'm a little bit
passionate about it
i love it and i wanna i wanna keep on
the passion going with this conversation
because i just love it tell me a little
bit more about the the six forms of
capital and and about what it takes for
for for this fourth wave of
entrepreneurship to grow a community and
make a return on the investment
i mean i think you know if you think
about what i think that really this
boils down to the the difference there's
a really great um
illustration which is ego versus eco and
a lot of times we think of ourselves as
separate from the ecosystem which has
caused a lot of the challenges of where
we are right now we believe that we are
above the ecosystem and we are not a
part of it therefore what we do doesn't
really matter when in reality we are
part of the ecosystem we are par
everything there is no a way when you
throw something out there's it's a
closed-loop system and you can't go
anywhere but we seem to forget that so
when we are looking at measurements of
growth generally speaking when you look
at economic growth it is measured by the
gbp which is the general uh the gross
domestic
product which has to do with has there
been economic growth in the company in
the country well of course there is war
is something that contributes to
economic growth divorce is something
that that contributes to economic growth
mental health which is a massive issue
within this specific pandemic is
something that continues to that that
contributes to economic growth and if
you look at what are some of the
different types of capital that we can
take a look at such as environmental
capital such as community capital such
as um i do not remember the five types
of capital now
but there are five types
and if you look at expanding the notion
of what actually what what return do i
want to do and how do i want to
contribute
that makes a difference in terms of
shifting your understanding of what
actually am i investing in and how do i
want how do i want it what kind of
impact do i want to make in the world
which goes back to a very basic tenet in
judaism which is tikkun olam which is um
you you have a role in responsibility to
be able to make the world a better place
than what you entered into so i think
that everything is you know everything
is interconnected
that's my answer
no that's my passion where
where do you think we're headed with
this fourth wave of entrepreneurship do
you think it'll stick do you think we're
headed into a fifth wave later on that
is going to be presenting and it's some
different ideals what's gonna what's
what's gonna take for really a lot of a
lot of the new entrepreneurs to decide
to go in in the route that you're
suggesting
i think that i mean i think that there
are a couple of things i it depends on
the day i either wake up completely
optimist or i wake up like now the world
is screwed not got nothing to do let's
just party like it's 1999. um
i think that you know one of the so in
terms of like some of the trends that
are happening in investment but also in
uh in consumer behavior
um you know i've been a vegetarian since
i was 13 a simple example and i remember
when i decided that i wanted to be a
vegetarian my mom's like okay
learn how to cook and let's go to like
the hippie you know court store that is
in the middle of nowhere in order to be
able to get you some tofu which i don't
know what this is
and now i mean veganism is on the rise
um you know vegetarianism is everywhere
the whole organic movement so with
anything that has to do with the change
it definitely reaches a tipping point
and it takes quite a while for that to
arrive so i think that we're still we're
still at we're still in a process of
change
both in terms of consumer behavior i
mean we both know that the consumer the
consumer need has shifted um you know
the younger generation refused to buy
things unless there's some kind of
ethical aspect behind it whether that
has to do with environmental recycled
clothing or whether that has to do with
makeup that is uh that is ethically
sourced there's a lot more of a rising
of awareness around that and then the
other aspect that you have is you have
entrepreneurs who are um who are
basically saying well i don't want to
define myself as one or the other i just
want to be able to do something and i
want to be able to use business as a
vehicle to be able to do that and that
is definitely growing there's no doubt
about that in terms of actual do i have
stats to show that that is probably i
can find them but i can tell you working
in the ecosystems for the past 15 years
100 that's happening and then you have
like this other thing that you have is
you have this rise of what i call um i
call the legacy investor and that's
someone who is in their you know in
their 50s and their 60s and they
suddenly are like oh um i have kids
now and i want to be able to make the
world a better place
what can i invest in that is going to
make the world a better place so you
know impact investment is one of the
fastest growing sectors in the world at
the moment and i think that it's kind of
in the same place as what corporate
social responsibility was about 25 years
ago and it's going to get to a place
where it's suddenly a lot more the
language has to change the market
signals have to change your narrative
around being able to understand that
everything is interconnected and that
you that what you do matters is going to
change i'm i'm an optimist from that
perspective but um the pessimist in me
says
a lot of times what we do is we adapt to
the problem and we refuse to actually
solve the root of the problem
so a perfect example around that is
climate change i mean none of us are
seemed to be willing to say all right
well we're going to tackle this head on
and all of the countries are going to
agree i mean i'm australian i'm i'm many
things i'm australian uh and australian
government the prime minister refuses to
acknowledge that there's climate change
i mean i'm sorry what
your country is going to be under water
let's talk so inst and temperatures are
rising and instead of people saying hold
on let's stop for a second and actually
take a look at what is the issue that we
have to resolve
we adapt right so we use technology to
be able to adapt such as for example
we're probably going to be wandering
around with aircon
uh suits that we can wear that'll
regulate our body temperature and
prevent it from being so hot yes we you
know like there's a whole bunch of
different ways to be able to adapt and
we are very very good at adapting rather
than facing the truth and solving the
actual underlying issue
right now obviously i can see the
excitement and they you know what
inspires you with this but take me back
a little bit to to what really
fascinated you as a kid you know you're
mentioning that you became vegetarian at
13 and you had this conviction
what what really you know what what made
you curious as a kid did you know that
you were going to be working with impact
and sustainability were you curious
about other things
i was always a really curious kid i i
have um
i used to go to the library
and uh
go randomly into the library and choose
a whole bunch of different books to read
so i've read like i think i read
um i i read uh books on neuroscience
when i was 10. uh i read books on
meditation i would just go into the
library and just be like okay what do i
want to read now um my parents are
massive book nerds and um
[Music]
i don't know that i knew
i don't know that i knew that i was
going to deal with sustainability but i
you know i've had very specific i can
see when i look back i can see very
clear pivots in my career and in what i
chose to do that kind of gave me
foundations for each different
perspective in each different lens that
lead to where i am today so you know my
first iteration of a career was working
in the outdoors and if you work in the
outdoors then you understand that
everything is interconnected that you
were operating within
like literally an ecosystem and learning
how to speak the ecosystem and learning
how to understand how to use nature as a
as a tool for healing and how um how the
trees talk to each other and how what
level you know what stage the forest is
at in terms of growth you can understand
cyclical issues you can understand how
psychology works and how people interact
with change how people differ like how
people change from being in an office
environment to being able to be outdoors
and being able to experience like a
common you know a fundamental um
emotion that people connect with and
then i started working in community
development and community economic
development and understanding like how
how do you actually how do you build
community and how do you actually build
trust with someone and how do you how do
you you know there's a saying in
community economic development which is
you give someone you teach someone to
fish rather than provide them with a
fish well it's also like understanding
the cultural context of the environment
that you're operating in understanding
the different language and the different
narrative the different perspectives the
different biases so you build on okay i
understand that everything is
interconnected i understand this is how
to build community how do you build
organizations and how do you do change
within organizations and then how do you
do business like how do you how do you
start thinking about how to how to meld
that i come from a place of the heart
and i have a very strong
vision and mission towards life but i
still need to be able to make money and
money is not necessarily a negative
thing so how do i how do i spin that
narrative in a more positive way um
so i don't i'm in curiosity i've always
been a very curious kid i i'm like i'm
like the random facts lady i love as
much information as possible downloaded
into my brain the matrix i really want
the matrix you know when you download a
specific program into your brain i'm
like i can do kung fu now watch me
i love it tia thank you so much for
coming on the show and what are three
words that you would use to describe
yourself
uh curious
[Laughter]
i think i i think that i uh i i work
very hard on being compassionate and
grounded i'm very i'm i like being able
to understand where the other person is
coming from
um and focused i'm very driven and i'm
very focused i think sometimes most of
the time
tia goldstein thank you so much for the
good that you're doing to the world
thank you for sharing your time with me
i really appreciate it best of luck with
you
thank you and and i and really thank you
for your time this was great
take care i appreciate it thank you very
much